I've got some of your family I met your
brother and my brother my brother your
mom I don't think I met your mom but
she's quite a character she really is
yeah she's she was very fun very
eccentric
very outgoing she was to be very proud
of you she's very proud of me yeah she
is she's very proud mom she wears a
shirt sometimes that she had made is
that right that's right I feel like this
is turning into like I'm a trial lawyer
is it not true that your mother wears a
shirt all right it's true
are you a picture of this shirt maybe
you can tell us what it is there okay
big dick Ritchie's mom
like I know where you're going with this
stuff so soon as you say that I'm like
oh god okay
love that I have photo evidence to back
up everything I brought up tonight yeah
no I'm just first of all I think it's
adorable that she would do that and it's
funny that she is just gonna she's gonna
go with that she's she's gonna do that
she's gonna wear that shirt everywhere
well my mom goes down like the local
Starbucks is like my mom's Cheers
so she goes down there and wears that
down there and hangs out with her
friends and wears his big dick Ritchie's
mom shirt that she had no I don't even
know where she got it I have no idea
where one makes a shirt like that right
it's she cool if other people start
talking about it too is she is she cool
like if other people start you know
talking about oh yeah I saw that movie
or I saw the sequel is she cool with
that likes yes as long as they don't get
off-color I mean there was a series of
whether it was true blood or Magic Mike
where a lot of this was very difficult
for mom to watch yeah and yeah I think
some one of her friends made some
off-color remark to her about like ooh
you know whatever and my mom kind of
said hey shut up that's my son how you
know like God got angry about it well
we're very much yeah my mom used to go
to the grocery store and she was
literally the guy bagging the grocery
should be like do you like television
God be like yeah TVs all right do you
like late-night television I guess so do
you like Conan O'Brien
he's all right do you want a keychain
like 10 of them in her purse that she
had made illegally
you